in this video we're going to introduce
ourselves to the idea of adding decimals
and I encourage you as we work through
these problems to keep pausing the video
and seeing if you can think about it on
your own before we work through it
together and we're going to build up
slowly and in future videos we're going
to find out faster ways of doing it but
the way we're learning it in this video
in the next view is to really make sure
we understand what is happening so let's
say we wanted to add zero point one two
zero point eight or you could say we're
adding one tenth to eight tenths pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out well there's a couple of ways
to think about it you could say hey look
zero point one that is 1/10 and zero
point eight that is eight tenths and so
if I have one of something and I add
eight more of that something so if one
tenth and I'm going to add eight more
tents well I'm going to end up with nine
of that something in this case we're
talking about tenths so that is going to
be equal to nine tenths that's one way
to think about it another way we could
think about it visually so let's say we
take a whole and we were divided into
tenths which we have right over here so
if we say this whole square as a whole
we divided into ten equal sections so
each of these white bars you can view as
a tenth so we have one tenth so let me
fill that in so one tenth whoops that's
not what I wanted to do we have one
tenth right over there and to that we
want to add eight tenths so one two
three four five six seven eight and so
how many total tenths do I now have well
let's just count them up we have this
one here one two three four five six
seven eight nine these are really saying
the same thing all of this together is
going to be a little neater all of this
together is going to be nine tenths now
in either case how do we write nine
tenths in decimal form well we go to the
tenth place which is one space
on the right side of the decimal we say
hey we have 9/10 this is the tenth space
right over here so that's just saying we
have nine tenths we have nine we have
nine of these tenths right over here so
let's keep building let's try to do
let's do another example so let's say
that we let me clear all of this out so
let's say that we want to add do these
with different colors so let's say we
want to add
I have trouble it's my pen isn't working
let's see let's say we want to add my
pen is oh here we go
let's say we want to add three tenths
and to that we want to add nine tenths
what is that going to be well you could
do use the same idea if you say this is
three tenths and this is 9/10 plus nine
tenths well that's three of something
and if I add nine of them well that's
going to be 12 3 plus 9 is 12 so we
could say this is going to be equal to
12 tenths now this one might be a little
bit counterintuitive twelve tenths what
does that mean well one way to think
about it this is 10 10 10 10 plus 2/10
and what are 10 tenths well if I have
ten tenths this right over here is one
whole so that is going to be 1 so we
have 1 & 2 tenths so how do we write 1 &
2 tenths well we could write it as in
the ones place we just write a one and
then then in the tenths place we write
our two tenths so it's you could say
it's equal to 1.2 or you could say it's
equal to 1 & 2 tenths which is the same
thing as 12 tenths now if we want to see
that visually let's get our diagram out
again
so actually I'm going to make put two of
these here so one and then a second one
and we want to add so let's start with
the 3/10 so let me color these in really
fast so use that light blue color so
that is 1/10
this is 2/10 its coloring them in really
fast and this is 3/10 and then to that
we're going to add nine tenths so to
that we're going to add one two three
I'm not coloring them in fully four you
get the idea
five almost there
six and you're color faster seven seven
eight nine so there you have it I have
added nine tenths you notice I've
colored in nine I've colored in yellow
nine of the tents and before I had three
of the tenths colored in and when you
add them all together what happens well
the three tenths plus the seven tenths
right over here they made a hole so this
right over here is our one and then we
also have another two tenths left over
and so this is where this is our 0.2 or
two tenths so it's going to be one plus
two tenths which is one point two so
hopefully this gives you a good sense of
how we think about adding decimals and
even though in the future we're going to
figure out faster ways of doing it or
miss more systematic ways of doing it
this is still the way that that I still
do it in my head if someone walks up to
me on the street and says hey add 0.3 to
0.9 that's how I think about it